bonjour laurent cesari merci de répondre
à nos questions des célébrations
maintenu donc ce soir malgré un record
de contamination du courant navires us
en moins de 24 heures par des dernières
24 heures qu'en pensent les américains
je pense que c'est une question très
clivant du point de vue politique qui on
veut et qui est activé par treuil dans
le cadre de sa campagne j'ai un petit
sondage de la fondation kaiser que j'ai
vu hier
37% des républicains portent
régulièrement le masque 70% des
démocrates ne le font pas je ne vais pas
porter un masque au contraire excusez
moi donc c'est très net il ya une e
c'est un marqueur politique les
républicains peuvent être contre le
contre le match que contre les
protections soient au nom de l' de la
liberté individuelle entendu dans un
sens libertarien on a vu par exemple des
femmes république elle reprendre les
slogans féministes dans mon corps
m'appartient
sous-entendu pas à l'état et cetera il
ya aussi à écouter
inversement masculinistes traits marqués
le masque refusé parce que les gaulois
larry de la virilité
parce que c'est une protection et on
voit très nettement que la trump dans le
cadre de sa campagne met en avant
justement la réouverture rapide de
déconfinement de l'économie contre le
port du masque et il en a que dans
l'extrait que vous avez vendre il y en a
parlé dans son discours avec des
chiffres assez trompeur puisque
justement la baisse du chômage dont il a
parlé au mois de juin ne tient pas
compte de la
nouvelle reprise du chômage induite par
le fait que la pandémie reprend
extrêmement fort et implique justement
des mesures de confinement dans des
états importants texas arizona
californie
vous parlez du port du masque il ya
évidemment cette polémique aux états
unis donald trump a parlé cette nuit il
n'a pas évoqué les chiffres de la
pandémie qui ne semble pas s'enrayer et
il a préféré axer son discours sur la
polémique des symboles qui agitent le
pays depuis plusieurs semaines qu'est ce
que ça traduit pour ce qui est des
symboles là aussi je pense que c'était
la cnlcc l'opposition frontale à toutes
les mesures d'intersection d'inviter les
les luttes noir les contrôles et les
déboulonnage de statut et cetera je
rappelle que il ya quelques jours
tron a lancé un tweet qu'il a ensuite
enlevé ou la une la foule de ses
partisans dans un meeting criaient
pouvoir blanc donc là aussi le clivage
est extrêmement nette atteignait 3 ans
est en mauvaise posture en ce moment
dans les sondages
qu'est ce qui peut se passer d'ici au 3
novembre date de la prochaine élection
américaine a le résidentiel où ce qui
est des deux des sondages de treuils
rouge et effectivement il est en baisse
et il est en baisse le même dans son
dans ce camp avec les les moins - les
ouvriers blancs fallait les blancs peu
qualifiés et cetera les blancs âgés et
blanc âgé qui lui reprochent fortement
la dame force de reprise du cdh hugo
ravi risque justement à déconfinement
très rapide
moi j'ai l'impression que trump très
nettement se recentre sur le noyau dur
de son électorat
il y à vraiment
cette droitisation tout à l'heure à
propos de la france est exactement la
même chose aux états unis alors il peut
certainement mobiliser son électorat le
plus fidèle ainsi mais comment dire
c'est l'ouverture me semble me semble
difficile
alors effectivement il est vrai que du
côté démocrate ça se polarise mettrait
moins nettement aussi à gauche puisque
by dane a fait des équipes où il a fait
la place à la gauche du parti a des
partisans de la dorada d'anciens
partisans de sanders
donc de là une élection qui va être très
très polarisée volontairement polarisée
par trump
je suis pas certain que ça réussisse
parce qu'effectivement ils baissent cela
dit il ya encore quelques mois bien sûr
merci laurence hézard et on va répondre
à nos questions je rappelle faciale est
des états unis est professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à l'université d'arras au
revoir merci